[Music]
guys today we're watching great personal
style and GQ style editor in chief we'll
Welch and today I'm here with Sid
Mashburn Obsidian we're in Atlanta
Georgia right suit absolutely this is my
hometown said where are you from I'm
from Mississippi which most people know
is the locus of fashion I was swimming
upstream as I left so this kindly agreed
to take us on a tour of his world we're
in the store we're gonna go to the
design studio that's across the street
in this home so she said take me through
the layout of this store all the pieces
that are in play and how that affects
the guy who walks through your door it
looks tailored yeah but not fancy or
fussy we want to appear like a James
Brown song it seems loose but it's tight
as it gets okay
the stores is meant to be like a
fraternity where everybody gets a bit we
like having the open door that tells you
to come in you're coming into our home
make yourself at home when you come in
to Sid Mashburn the clothes the vibe
everything about it lends itself to
style you can take it as advanced as you
want it but it's not like capital F
fashion right and to me that is a
beautiful sweet spot and all of us are
trying to get to we're here to serve men
but the creative satisfaction that comes
with that is us designing the clothes
the emotional satisfaction taking care
of someone you can't beat right and we
does to come together right it's
fantastic one thing that I love
especially coming from New York is
you're gonna see some color in here
we're always gonna see some color we
love coming and that's probably the most
southern thing that we bring to design
and also having fun with your clothes
not just coming off too seriously you
launched in 2007 yeah that's the same
year I started at GQ and I remember that
the preppy movement was happening how
have you seen that evolved and now that
all that trend aspect of has gone away
how have you evolved Sid Mashburn
unfortunately the preppy moniker seems
pejorative it's really just classic
clothes which are great foundations so
we still have that baseline of
foundation here and we're not going to
get rid of that
I said you do a lot of things here from
Levi's 501s to record players but a lot
of guys when they think of Sid Mashburn
they're like that's where I go to get my
suits where are you at right now with
the suit the role in the man's life and
whether it needs a tie and dress shoes
the suits gotten beaten up in years and
partly because people's lifestyles have
gotten a little more relaxed also
dressed because you've gotten a little
more relaxed but the irony of that
relaxed dress code is is it actually
shows some seeds of anxiety for some
guys it absolutely does there's nothing
worse than the rules going out the
window we try to take that back and
every guy in our whole company wears a
tie every day it's like it if you're
going to watch the Georgia play and a
guys in an Auburn uniform you're like
what the hell's he doing it how does the
Sid Mashburn suit let me move we're
trying to make the jacket not feel like
you're trussed up so it's not a farm
move to go start wearing that jacket
right it's a high audio you actually get
better mobility same thing for the
natural shoulders okay so the natural
shoulders gives you a little bit more
ease let's go see how these soups move
let's do it you ready
said I got one more question how did you
choose that tie this morning man I love
this time this is one of my favorites of
all favorites it is so whacked out and
this suit was a little tad sober I was
like you know what I want a little more
kick and if you'll notice if I take this
off I've got no lead singer right
Oh bad writing session move exactly so I
need the antique antique you gotta pick
treasure exactly kind of lift it up a
little bit
[Music]